good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight if you've seen video of
Joe Biden mumbling in public recently
and we bet you have there's probably not
anything we could tell you tonight
excuse me that's going to surprise you
would you be shocked to learn that Joe
Biden recently got lost in his own
bedroom that he introduced a table lamp
as his wife that he bragged to the
Japanese prime minister about saving
Marie Antoinette's life during a cavalry
charge in the Crimean War probably not
now we can't say that any of these
things actually happened but they could
have their entirely plausible
and if you think that's a mean thing to
say don't worry Joe Biden will never
know at this point other people are not
real to Joe Biden he lives in a world of
ghosts and fog shrouded memories but she
knew that because you've seen the tape
maybe the only thing that would surprise
you about Joe Biden 15 months into his
presidency is learning that he plans to
run for reelection now that would be
outlandish impossible really ridiculous
where Joe Biden somehow able to stay in
the white house he would be 86 years old
by the end of his second term do the
math on that even now at 79 past the
life expectancy of the average American
man Joe Biden can barely speak English
and that is not a trend that will
improve with time
what kind of President would Joe Biden
be by the year 2028 you shudder to think
about that that you can bet that more
Botox and hair plugs would not improve
him the whole idea is grotesque
weekended Bernie's White House Edition
it's an insult to the principle of
self-government
but that doesn't mean it's not coming
according to a piece this week in the
hill newspaper Joe Biden has confided in
his old boss Barack Obama that he does
in fact plan to run for re-election
Joe Biden believes he is quote the only
one who can beat Donald Trump which if
nothing else suggests that Joe Biden
believes he beat Donald Trump the first
time hey guys I got 81 million votes
maybe I'll get 500 billion next time
so how did Barack Obama respond to that
well the hill newspaper didn't say we do
know that earlier this month Obama
referred to Joe Biden as quote vice
president so you can guess Obama never
hid the fact that he didn't like or
respect Joe Biden Obama thought Biden
was fake and incompetent old white and
annoying and that was 10 years ago so
you can imagine how Obama feels but the
prospect of an 86 year old President Joe
Biden now Michelle Obama by contrast
will have just turned 60 by the time the
next presidential election rolls around
so clearly it's her turn
it's not just Obama who feels this way a
lot of Democrats agree
just for the sake of amusement this
morning we tried to find a Democratic
Party official who'd be willing to go on
the record to endorse a second Joe Biden
candidacy and we couldn't find a single
one
now keep in mind these are the same
people who are delighted to tell you
that you can change your biological sex
just by wishing it so
like Dorothy clicking her heels at Oz
boom you're transgender now they
consider that believable
yet they will not tell you that Joe
Biden should be president again a Biden
reelection campaign is just too absurd
even for them it strains credulity past
the breaking point Joe Biden come on
that's the consensus in Washington
tonight and for once it is correct
so given that now you know what is going
on with the news media Joe Biden's most
loyal constituency has turned on him
with a Vengeance after getting the
mannequin elected the White House Press
Corps is telling you night after night
he's a loser why are they saying this
because they don't want him to run again
they know he will lose
watch CNN remind you that Joe Biden is
now less popular than most sexually
transmitted diseases
these numbers kind of differ they range
from the low 30s to the low 40s low 40s
is not good either but what's key is the
lowest are tied for the low for the
pollster lowest tier lowest tier this is
one point off the lowest lowest tier and
when you have three or four pollsters
showing the lowest numbers for the
president United States that is
indicative of a president who's in a lot
of trouble at least to where he has
standed historically this is the lowest
for anyone who is elected to the
presidency and didn't get up there
through the vice presidency this is a
really really really bad number
okay so that's one piece of tape but
it's not just a single oily pole reader
on CNN pretty much every media Outlet in
the country is saying the same things
they've gone beyond reading the terrible
poll numbers and now they're agreeing
with the terrible poll numbers here's
Chief Biden Toady Chuck Todd of NBC
quote news turning on his former Patron
live on television it's like a scene
from The Godfather ooh the Betrayal
watch this
folks it's one thing for a trump judge
to strike down an order from the Biden
white house but it's an entirely
different thing for the White House to
let it happen without any legal pushback
and it's not the first time recently
that something hasn't gone the White
House's way
they don't fight back they don't defend
their rationale the bite Administration
with the full power and Prestige of the
presidency with his party's power in
Congress on the line This November has
repeatedly looked as if they're easy to
roll
oh they're easy to roll of course
they're easy to roll no one respects the
old guys passed his prime ignore him
he's napping
and that was Joe Biden's biggest fan
talking Chuck Todd is the guy who once
informed you it was immoral not to vote
for the dementia patient from Delaware
this is a National Emergency suspend
disbelief ignore what you see don't call
Joe Biden senile that's a hate crime
it's ageism
and the shouting works it always works
so for a while almost nobody said the
obvious of course everybody knew it it
was impossible not to know it in case
you've forgotten here's what Joe Biden
looked like during the last presidential
campaign
look tomorrow's Superstar Tuesday and I
want to thank you all
I tell you what I'm rushing ahead aren't
I
150 million people have been killed
since 2007 when Bernie voted to exempt
the gun manufacture some liability it
would put
720 million back million women back in
the workforce nobody should be in jail
for a non-violent crime my name is Joe
Biden I'm a Democratic candidate for the
United States Senate what's not to like
about Vermont in terms of the beauty of
it and what a neat Town play the radio
make sure the television excuse me make
sure you have the record player on at
night more kids are just as bright and
just as tall as white kids we choose
science over fiction we choose truth
over facts think about it we owe these
truths to be self-evident all men and
women created by the goal you know the
you know the thing
you know the thing and indeed we did
know the thing we recognized the thing
immediately it's called Galloping
dementia it's a very sad thing
it's coming for a lot of us on the other
hand a lot of us are not the president
of the United States leaders of big
countries have to be able to think
clearly Joe Biden couldn't do that he
has not been able to do that for years
now
but you would never know the truth about
Joe Biden from the news coverage that's
surrounded and protected him for more
than a year
here's a representative sample of the
happy talk you saw night after night on
television
you'll notice if you listen carefully to
this that it has a strained almost
desperate quality to it they knew they
were lying but they didn't think they
had a choice dad's not drunk again he's
just really tired watch
how refreshing
how human
how compassionate
how American Biden tried to lift our
Spirits with a medicinal message about
recovering our sense of collective cause
certainly it was healing he didn't say
you need me
he said I need you
I need you
I mean my God that is isn't that it
people always talk about the feeling of
the relief they have hearing Biden but
what he's doing now soars above that
well the president is saying is help is
on the way we're all in this together
I need your help
we're all Americans
Hallelujah
Hallelujah
so no ladies and gentlemen Joe Biden
isn't staring blankly off into the
middle distance he is not reading lists
of cliches he couldn't possibly
understand no not at all that's not what
you're seeing here Joe Biden is emoting
he's healing he's soaring on the
rhetoric of Pericles above a Grateful
Nation propelled Aloft by gentle Zephyrs
of Hope that's what Joe Biden is doing
oh please
why couldn't they just tell us the truth
we saw it ourselves it might have helped
if the media had been honest before the
election Mark Zuckerberg might not have
dropped 419 million dollars to swing the
outcome of the election and this would
be a different country
but it's too late now we're stuck with
him so here he is this is from a
televised event this fall you'll notice
among other things that Biden is holding
out his hands like a doll for no obvious
reason
just in terms of inflation because you
had told us at a town hall I think it
was in July that the in this was just
near-term inflation The Wall Street
Journal recently talks is like 67 uh
Financial experts who said that they
they saw High inflation going all the
way or deep into 2022.
that was from a CNN Special it's a full
hour designed produced to Showcase Joe
Biden's strengths and his fundamental
awesomeness
now imagine what he must be like around
the office where there are no cameras or
special injections from the White House
Physicians to clear his head
it's got to be Thanksgiving at the rest
home with Biden sitting alone making
designs in his mashed potatoes his
co-workers are clearly worn out by this
if not affirmatively sick of the whole
thing watch what happened at the White
House earlier this month and remember as
you view this that virtually everyone in
the room Works for Joe Biden but they're
ignoring him anyway
foreign
[Music]
so that's the polite version of what
happened that day here's the scene
moments later with Barack Obama the
rudest president in American history
Obama never liked Joe Biden and he's
hardly going to start pretending to now
we should warn you this is horrible
yeah
yeah
[Music]
we could play clip after clip after clip
like that we've got a whole montage with
Joe Biden referring to Kamala Harris as
the President of the United States
spoiler alert she's not
but why belabor it the whole thing's
depressing you get it everyone gets it
the Democratic party installed Joe Biden
in a last desperate effort to stop the
economic populism of Bernie Sanders and
then in the general election in efforts
to silence the uncontrollable talking of
Donald Trump
to be clear permanent Washington never
feared what Donald Trump would do it was
pretending to fear that what actually
legitimately terrified them was what
Donald Trump might say
what if Trump started noting obvious
things and then the whole system came
tumbling down that could happen words
are the one thing you can't take back so
it was not worth the risk to keep trump
it absolutely had to be Joe Biden
they assumed Joe Biden would be grateful
for the promotion a ceremonial
retirement gig one last government sign
a cure before the end but somewhere
along the way things changed as they
often do Joe Biden forgot the terms of
the deal he started running up to
microphones and pretending to be
president at a certain point the Kabuki
went to his head and then he decided he
might actually run for reelection what
the hell I got 81 million votes the
first time
for the Democratic party this was
disaster Frankenstein had escaped the
lab
so they had to take him out and now they
are
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight